forget about it  if you're not on the list you're not  getting inside  private party come back back off  yeah  what do you want  sean where can i find him  guys  we got a problem here  please don't hit me  [Music]  stop him for [ __ ] sake  [Music]  uh  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  [Music]  the [ __ ] is this  [Music]  [Music]  oh  stop him [ __ ] sake  [Music]  oh  [Music]  [Music]  thank you  ugh  [Music]  [Music]  the two giants over there  what's behind their door  excellent  [Music]  this part of the club's off limits  [Music]  this  hmm  [Music]  that's closed tonight  um  no way  oh  come on chad kick his ass i got a [ __ ]  ton of money riding on you  get him harder  what the hell is going on here  [Music]  huh  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  wake up  um  what are you doing  [ __ ]  [Music]  that can't be possible  you